hey guys welcome to destiny let's play
number three I got rid of the face cam
because I just finished editing video
too she can be super weird if you're
watching this because you'll probably
already have seen it but yeah there was
like a weird audio lag and so it took
forever to edit and it's also just way
less fun for me so I'm sorry to those
who enjoyed it and to those who didn't
you're welcome and we're taking off
exactly where we left off so this is
also still on earth of course it's
always the way hey go find this thing
it's for the good of humanity bro ah
every game who cares about humanity
except humans obviously seconds it's a
really small amount of time okay where
we going buddy over here okay
let us do the thing I got some initial
impressions of Destiny so far you guys
though is that like well it's really fun
the gameplay super fun enemies are
repetitive and it doesn't have that much
personality I guess like I know that I'm
gonna have so much fun playing this game
with a party I just can't do that while
I'm lads playing it because I don't know
how to do that editing like I wouldn't
know how to have my audio whilst also
talking to other people i don't know how
to do it maybe I'll um look into that
one day but it's kind of the same is
titanfall where when I play by myself I
just like fun it kind of mindless and
dumb but when I play it with friends
it's the most fun thing ever and I think
that this is going to be exactly like
that but on its own while I appreciate
that you can play it by yourself and it
just feels like oh shoot oh which is
good because sometimes i like being
antisocial when i play MMOs yeah it
doesn't doesn't have like a sense of
humor like a lot of MMOs do they like
you know even just have like some little
cheeky bits it doesn't feel like it was
really made with um I guess a
personality or identity in mind it just
feels very sad
ok
OOP ooh hey buddy damn it accidentally
press the wrong button sorry another one
I think there was another one oh you
would know you're up bro right uh hello
uh I wrote it Randall Shh ah too far
away um so you have right now like well
this gave me a super fun and yet looking
forward to playing with friends I don't
I like I think it's gonna wear pretty
thin I think that in a week or so or
even when just getting to the end game
it might not be quite as good I think
that I'm probably going to get bored to
be honest because it's just not that
it's not that engrossing really but
we'll see obviously I haven't played
very much but just yet so that my mind
could be completely changed and this is
really just the start of the game start
of games especially in MMOs tends to be
pretty basic until stuff gets you no
more intense so so that's just what I'm
feeling so far but no that's totally
totally likely to change I guess we'll
see you it seemed like a lot of posts to
the community where they just talked
about how much they love it so maybe
those people who played more than I have
or I don't know I wouldn't think so it
doesn't mean out for that long and I've
played like I mean quite a lot in the
time that's been out it's been out in
Australia for I don't know a few hours
so I don't know kind of magic many
people have played that much more than
me by now but who knows really yeah go
ghost you go you guard him
get away get away oh no oh no I thought
it that I was supercharged but I am NOT
ah damn it should have retreated earlier
um but maybe i'll make like it because
i'm gonna gonna do three of these let's
play videos for now and like i said oh
make mole when it gets towards the end
of the game I think to show you guys
different stuff but maybe i'll make like
a like a early review sometime this week
of something for the other people who
kind of just want to know what's up
straight away I might just do like a
pros and cons thing and it depends how
much time we have I'm probably not gonna
have time to do that let's be real but
what is that talking what about come
from a supercharged sort of fight me ol
oh ok a very see us up on over here
y'all let's check it oh hey another
person Wow why is somebody's level 20
and I split Ozzy wrong is that supposed
to be i'll see like a stray lien you
spelt it rumber so and I spell it um I
swear it said I was supposed to go he
didn't know we going up that okay yeah
like what's a little 20 doing here maybe
they playing with someone else no but
then I'd be on a CD a plasma because
it's like a level 4 mission like even if
you were going to grind you'd think
you'd do it on something a little bit
higher
where is he why'd he go what are you I
was gonna see if you wanted to dance Oh
what oh I thought he was behind that ah
really he totally just died are you
kidding me that's ridiculous rubbish
absolutely rubbish
but the noise that comes from that thing
is so weird it's like unsettling I don't
like it I delight at all
well I'm sure glad we scan both okay
let's check it out let's do the thing
you see old are a complex to locate this
I am I supposed to get up to orbit no no
evidence all right coming this way hey
ballsy spot in spout room do you want to
dance get your wash back here come back
you just wanna dance what are you wanna
dance with me yeah I get you ass I've
you know nobody wants to dance you guys
and it's really disappointing okay come
on dance it's not interested not even
interested screw that guy because the
sub is are so unpopulated I just want to
dance with everyone I see and nobody
ever wants to dance with me man why is
nobody interested in dancing each other
they will get like way more populated
over the next few days
but guess we'll we'll have to wait and
see how that goes all right it's a lot
of walking around same kind of
architecture this totally doesn't remind
me of halo 3 at all just kidding it does
oh I had a little party invites about a
lot of people doing party invites
especially like when I first got on I
assume from just other people who are
like midnight launches for the game um I
like the time let's playing I'm not
ignoring you just don't time man oh it's
bus time oh oh hi there hello there
shiny thing
okay oh my god there's lots of them so
many wait so this isn't the boss fight
maybe it's not can't tell if that
borrowed hmm it's got to be though cuz
that's usually the only time this
happens yeah but I um didn't actually
get this fall in is your beta which is
really just because I was in Sydney that
week why was I even sending I remember I
was in Sydney for two of the beta
weekends um just kind of bummed about it
meant that I missed out I managed to get
like a while on the ps4 and then when it
launched on the Xbox one I was also away
so sucked I mean it doesn't really
matter no there doesn't the fallen or
bunch of douchebags that's what they are
nothin this one's shooting me hey Jack
Jack faces I know I wasted that that was
such a waste worst ever new new new new
new new new
poof poof who's that oh my god no
there's so many damn overwhelmed oh
that's right suck in the light mist the
lamest ever Oh brought me back here
that's good
I think that was like a heavier one nice
aim someone up here oh no so many of
them it's crazy stuff they're everywhere
vandals at the elites oh my god so many
so many so many so many so many this
music is so halo duty it's actually
quite nice music though score is pretty
good so far nice and Atmospheric and
quite climactic and stuff oh my god and
many of you all there just died they
were a spawning is there like a boss
this night on diegan are no I'm like why
is this how many of them hey because if
there's a boss that would make sense
it's like really often there anything
there is man I think there is I just
think those just heaps of them in you
just like they always respawn in those
bosses around well I'm pretty sure the
shanks in you so learnt here before I
don't think so that seems like
progression
ok God
alright health get on it how many of you
are there Jesus well okay health is
folded captain is a jerk I still done a
damn soup each LG thing takes so long to
come back I wish I could teleport
wouldn't that be sweet oh oh oh too far
away
there we go supercharged
even that kind of isn't really enough to
killer captain though lez be honest but
we can't did I get him no I did I kill
him no way I think I did wow that's
amazing and then boom there's another
one right there you just keep coming out
and I just don't even you just don't
even expect them to be there and they're
like hey what's up oh hey you want to
hang out deskey yeah I'm gonna have to
watch out for this captain right screw
you buddy and I'll screw you and your
shield suck it yes is that it that's it
I think oh my god it's not are you
kidding me so many of you this is
ridiculous
jaysus this is some hectic stuff right
here honestly though this is probably
the most fun fight I've had in this game
so far because it is quite overwhelming
we found being honest so that's good I
guess a lot of the others have just been
like kind of like fairly simple really
so this one certainly different which is
cool
well maybe it's not different difference
probably don't throw I would it's just
more of it I guess so and it's in this
little bit less predictable the things
that's throwing at me I'm not expecting
so it's that's nice
I'm all about not expecting things how
about now and immune and how do I
destroy it then but it says immune no no
maybe it doesn't I swear it said that
here we go cool so I guess instead of
having a boss low mini-boss there they
just um shot that flood at me it's
worked out pretty well it was fun good
stuff well let's do that then don't know
okay well that is it for my destiny
let's play you guys I hope you guys have
enjoyed it when I get to the end of the
game I'll make some more stuff and I
guess if that that's if you guys want it
to a comment and let me know if you
would like to see more I hope you guys
have enjoyed this sorry about the north
face cam screw that it was not fun and
also really hot headed I'll see y'all
next